hey youtubers is Charlie so Rick and
Morty has a whole bunch of theories a
whole bunch of secrets I'm going to be
explaining the biggest one and a big
season3 update so here we go there is a
new round of the giveaway going on now -
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything there are a lot of secrets
about Rick and Morty some of them
funnier than others but the biggest is
that there is a highly serialized story
line that's running in the background
then they call like the secret storyline
that you only get Inklings of in the
first two seasons that they'll also
continue to tease out in season 3 and
that is is that not every episode
follows the same Rick and Morty Rick has
a dimension portal gun so he goes to
different dimensions in every episode
but on top of that because there are
infinite Rick's like we have the Council
of Rick's which I'll talk about in a
second the episodes are not necessarily
following the same Rick and Morty every
single week the two best examples of
that are the season 2 episodes morty
night run in total Rick all
I don't know how this works something
what da hell I know right
so Morty night run shows you the
interdimensional Jerry daycare where
they mix up Jerry's at the end of the
episode and Rick can't remember which
Jerry from which universe belongs to him
so he kind of just rolls the dice and
says I don't care that much whatever
let's go hey Morty there's our Jerry hmm
I missed you
hey Rick glad you're safe Jerry what do
you say we go home I'd like that
hey wait do you have five one two six
I'm not sure Morty uh that's a Blitzen
chits ticket what way to go Morty yeah
whatever
uh wait what all right come on Jerry so
one one level the moments just meant to
be really funny make you question your
sanity wait a minute is five one two six
Rick and Morty the people we started the
episode with or is it this other Rick
and Morty or is it like another version
so you just spiral out of control and if
you were wondering the Rick and Morty
that we typically follow in each episode
is c-137
dimension Rick and Morty but on another
level it's meant to poke fun at how TV
shows are really bad at keeping their
own continuity Doctor Who is a TV show
that's notorious for breaking its own
continuity but the brilliant thing that
I think that Dan Harmon Ryan Ridley
Justin roiland have done is embrace this
chaos and just write it into the show
yeah maybe we don't leave the episode
with the same Rick and Morty as we did
at the beginning of the episode speaking
of episodes that make you question your
sanity the next best example that we're
not following the same Rick and Morty
every single week is Total Recall in
episode that aired a couple weeks after
this first example is anyone here even
real am I the only real person on earth
maybe or maybe just maybe we're all real
you know me I'm reversed Arab I have a
short neck and legs I went to college
with hammer-on hey I saved ghosts in the
jaws life in Vietnam and Beth how many
times have I been a shoulder for you to
cry oh ah too many okay
so maybe with just all things Total
Recall is one of my favorite episodes
for a number of reasons but mr. poopy
butthole this character here if you're
not familiar with him that's
his name he says he's been living with
the family for this whole time but they
find out that there are mental parasites
living off of them and they can't trust
with all the new characters that
continually pop up say eventually they
figure out that the parasites are only
capable of generating happy memories so
if they have terrible memories of
someone like summer beating Morty
then we know that summer is real oh oh
really
well I remember you as a whiny little
piece of [ __ ] Morty oh yeah yeah I've
got about a thousand memories of your
dumb little ass and about six of them
are pleasant the rest is annoying
garbage so why don't you do us both a
favor and pull the trigger
do it do it mother pull the trigger
oh wow baby wizard was a parasite he set
me up with my wife what's the hell I
figured it out Rick the parasites can
only create pleasant memories I know
you're real because I have a ton of bad
memories with you so eventually it comes
down to mr. poopy butthole and Beth
cannot remember anything bad about him
so thinking that he's a parasite
shoots him but he turns out to be real
and that means that he's been telling
the truth this whole time he's been with
the family they even added him to the
credits the opening credits of the
episode just to make you feel like he's
been with this family for all of these
seasons just taken in the context of
this episode that was really them just
messing with the audience a little bit
like hey see he's been here this whole
time this is going to be a really funny
joke but it actually fits into the
continuity of the show and that's one of
the other big secrets about the show
itself so it's just further evidence
that we don't always follow the same
Rick and Morty from the same dimension
every single time because there is a mr.
poopy butthole that's lived with the
family for the whole time in a dimension
but like during season one we don't
visit his dimension at all there are
infinite dimensions so that even means
that if we see mr. poopy butthole come
back during season three that it could
be a completely different version of the
character fall asleep
oh we this is how I die geez oh my god
the other big secret about this which i
think is a little bit funnier is is that
in making the show they try to say you
know read it proof it just like people
that pick through look for details find
things they try to add a lot of that in
the background just to make it a lot
more fun for the audience so in season
one for example they didn't really have
the idea about following different Rick
and Morty's in different dimensions
until they got to season two so the show
changes a little bit each season they
mess with the continuity but they do try
to make it all work together
[Music]
geez Rick what is this place Citadella
Rick's it's the secret headquarters for
the counselor Rick's
Council of bricks as you know Morty I've
got a lot of enemies in the universe to
consider my genius of threat galactic
terrorists a few sub-goal active
dictators most of the entire
intergalactic government wherever you
find people with heads up their asses
someone wants a piece of your crap one
of the best examples of this early on in
season one when they were still kind of
figuring the show out was when they
visited the Council of Rick's which is
actually based on the comic book Council
of reads a bunch of Reed Richards
banding together from different
universes different realities in working
together so it gives you a taste for the
idea that there are infinite Rick's out
there but it kind of breaks the season
to theory that we're not following the
same Rick and Morty just because new
episodes tend to start with Rick and
Morty's with the same haircuts that
almost look identical in way back in
season 1 when they're visiting the
council of ricks before they had this
all figured out on the left here this is
Rick prime meaning that he is the first
Rick so now recontextualized with what's
going on in season 2 not following the
same Rick and Morty you wonder what
happened to that first Rick and who is
the rig that we started with at the
beginning of season 1 well the answer
for that at the end of season 2 is this
Rick right here he's supposed to be the
first Rick and when they wrote the
Council of Rick's it was just intended
to be this big mind trip but now we come
to season 3 and they'll probably expand
all not even more like hey maybe maybe
something else is going on here so there
are a number of secret storylines and
I'll do more bonus videos for each of
them the other really big one is the
story of the Galactic government
pursuing all of the Rick's in all the
dimensions creating the need for the
council Rick's to be created so unless
they drop an actual season 3 trailer
that will probably be my next Rick and
Morty bonus video but feel free to
recommend videos in the comments like
mr. poopy butthole is the most powerful
character on Rick and Morty because he
knows that he's inside a TV show you
think of that finale huh hmm you think
this
Smith family's gonna be okay yeah I
don't know you talk my bro he totals
1237 we think Rick's gonna get out of
jail we think the family's gonna rescue
tune into Rick and Morty season three in
like a year and a half or longer to see
how we unravel this mess Oh II there's a
theory that Rick understands he's inside
a TV show and I know a lot of you have
asked for Easter egg videos but because
there are so many I could do videos for
every single episode that's happened so
far so I haven't quite figured out the
best way to accomplish that so bonus
videos will probably start off with
really big concepts and then I might do
some more specific episode videos but
you guys can just let me know what you
want
so season 3 just to give an update
recently they came out and said that
there's probably no way I mean it's
really too late now for it to air in
December originally that was the plan
but now it sounds like it might not even
air till March but no one has officially
confirmed that Adult Swim is pretty
notorious for just kind of waiting til
they're getting ready to air and then
just dropping stuff so really what I'm
expecting is is that when we get a
little bit closer the creator's will
actually start talking about it like
yeah we're probably going to be airing
in the next month or two but the big
holdup has been the animation like at
the end of the summer that was the
reason why they had to readjust their
air date so originally December now
closer to March of next year which is
okay but there'll be 14 episodes so
what'll probably happen is we'll see
that trailer sometime in January maybe
February usually it's at least a month
out from whenever the series airs is
when TV shows start really dropping new
footage so I will say congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner super Bob
you win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details you can blow it on Christmas
loot or whenever you want so I've
already started a new round in this
video I'll announce the winner when I
post that next Rick and Morty video so
get hype star wars Easter eggs coming
later tonight so make sure you go see
rogue one there are a ton of Easter eggs
for the other series as well is like
unused stuff that George Lucas did not
include in the original films while you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here from my non-spoilery rogue one
review and you can click here for the
trailer for the next
sort of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]